ça c'est toute votre enfance vous alliez
vous aux spectacles aux chantiers votre
chalet au spectacle le châtelet oui
c'est vrai que tiennent que le châtelet
qui a une grande place dans l'histoire
de ma famille mon mon père est joué chez
colonnes dans leur qu'istres colonnes
jean claude monfils a fait partie des
consorts colonnes mon fils dominique
probst fait partie des concerts colonne
mon petit fils olivier holt a dirigé
aussi au châtelet comme jean claude qui
a dirigé au shaq et j'avais je vous
réponds aussi une grand mère qui était
bioshock est bien la mère de madame de
mon arrière grand mère mon arrière grand
mère était comédienne et elle avait fait
entrer ça mais comme couturière
habilleuse au châtelet par éthique parce
que tout ça est se passe dans une époque
très lointaine même pour moi et oui le
châtelet une de mes soeurs et à chanter
la femme de jean claude il a été
danseuse étoile
vous riez le châtelet et c'est vrai
quand j'étais petite fille j'allais voir
des des spectacles au châtelet et
j'avais très peur notamment de michel
strogoff ça me passionner et voilà mais
je n'ai personnellement jamais joué en
championnat mais je crois pas mais c'est
en allant chatte l'île notamment je
crois dans l'envoi des opérettes que
vous avez envie aller se coucher il ya
la gaîté lyrique que l'union père était
directeur musical et oui quand j'étais
toute petite fille
mon père nous emmenait le dimanche mon
frère et moi voir les opérettes et on
nous mettait dans la fosse d'orchestre
ou bien sur le plateau entre deux portes
en condition l'un des petits casadesus
fusionner et je vous ai raconté je crois
que je sais pas si c'est à vous que et
nos parents nous avaient rapporté une
très belle patinette d'amérique du nord
et dans la belle hélène max dearly avait
demandé de faire une entrée sensationnel
et il voulait une patinette et mon père
lui a dû enfin mes enfants non une très
belle nous a pas demandé notre avis on
on a prêté à magas berline notre belle
patine est alors le dimanche en aller
voir la fatigue se fait râler
[Musique]